Apple's upcoming 2024 iPad lineup is
looking like it's going to be the best
we've seen in many years with multiple
new models coming soon but as of right
now which ones within the current lineup
are actually worth buying how do they
compare and which ones should you
absolutely avoid while we wait for the
new models let's jump right into the
first question by laying out precisely
which iPads we actually have right now
starting from the bottom we have the
iPad 10 for $450
the iPad Mini 6 for $500 the iPad air5
for 600 which I'm using as the
teleprompter right now the 11in iPad Pro
for $800 and the 12.9 in iPad Pro for
$1,100 however I do want to mention that
a bunch of these iPad models are on sale
for $100 off right now on Amazon like
the iPad 10 for only
$350 which is a killer deal so be sure
to check the links and the pinned
comment below for the best prices on
each iPad now in terms of Which models
are worth buying the good thing to knowe
is that they all share the same new
modern design language other than the
outdated iPad 9 which is actually still
an Apple's lineup and only 250 bucks on
Amazon so it's great for those going on
a budget but personally I think it's
totally worth spending the extra $100
for the iPad 10 because it gets a bunch
of new features that make it a lot more
like the more expensive models for
example it's got an edgo edge display
with rounded Corners all around which
looks amazing and very immersive
compared to the old boxy style it
finally has speakers on top which means
it has stereo audio which I would argue
is a must when using your iPad in
landscape mode for watching videos and
gaming it's also got a modern USBC port
to match what we have on the new iPhone
15s but the biggest downside is that the
one on the budget iPad 10 is limited to
the same very slow 480 megabits per
second transfer speed as the previous
iPad while the iPad Mini goes up to 5
gbits per second the air goes up to 10
and the pros have up to 40 with
Thunderbolt ports which are so much more
usable with docks and accessories the
iPad 10 also has the big disadvantage of
not supporting the apple pencil 2 with
its built-in magnetic wireless charging
feature which was actually terrible at
launch for the iPad 10 because users had
to get an adapter to connect the
original apple pencil so it was just a
mess but thankfully Apple just released
the brand new apple pencil USBC which
conveniently allows you to use the same
USBC cable that comes in the box of the
iPad for pairing and charging and this
one actually supports the magnetic
attachment feature but without the
wireless charging and best of all it's
only $79 compared to
$129 so honestly saving 50 bucks is
worth it since you don't need to charge
the pencil that often anyway now moving
on to more differences the iPad 10
actually has the advantage of coming
with a landscape 12 megap front camera
which makes it look a lot more natural
than the others that have the camera on
the top right here so it makes it look
like you're looking at the side and the
reason they don't get it is because
these iPad Pros have the wireless
charging for the apple pencil right in
the spot where the landscape camera was
would have gone however the display on
the iPad 10 isn't as good as the rest
because for one it only supports srgb
colors compared to P3 wide color on the
rest of the iPads so you can see that
the iPad 10 is the only one that doesn't
show this web kit logo and it also
doesn't get the same anti-reflective
coding which comes on the rest of the
iPads but even worse the display on the
iPad 10 is not laminated to the glass
like it is on all of the more expensive
iPads which is something that makes the
display thinner and makes the blacks
look darker in fact you can even see a
gap between the display panel and the
glass on the iPad 10 and you can even
hear the difference when tapping on it
you can hear that it's actually Hollow
compared to solid displays on the rest
on top of that it has the oldest chip
the A14 bionic which was known for
getting hot and simply not performing as
well as the rest as you can see it's the
slowest in terms of single Cor
performance although not too far off
from the a15 since that chip didn't have
a big single thread jump but multicore
is where you really see a big difference
in performance with the A14 really
lagging behind especially with the iPad
Pros M2 Chip being over twice as fast
and then Graphics is where it really
becomes worth spending extra cash for
the better iPads for things like gaming
and productivity work here you can see
that the iPad Pro is now almost three
times faster than the the A14 inside of
the iPad 10 and you might think that
over 45,000 points is overkill in terms
of Graphics but the iPad Pro also comes
with promotion 120hz display technology
which means that it can refresh 120
times a second so the display looks
super smooth compared to 60 HZ on the
rest of the cheaper iPads and the toll.
9in model also comes with mini LED
technology which makes the display look
incredible with deep blacks colors that
really pop and up to 1,000 in of
brightness compared to 500 on the budget
iPad so with that said you're probably
thinking I'm going to tell you that you
should absolutely avoid the iPad 10 but
honestly no this is the one I'm going to
recommend going into 2024 for three big
reasons number one is that more people
seem to be going on budgets this year
and this one is budget friendly at 350
bucks on Amazon and number two is that
when you stop looking at specific specs
and features it's still just as much of
an iPad as the rest of them for regular
iPad things like using apps watching
videos playing games and more sure you
won't get as good of an experience with
the worst display quality and slower
speeds but in reality it's good enough
for most people it's also got Wi-Fi 6
and Bluetooth 5.2 which is great and
will support a lot of accessories for
years to come and finally reason number
three is that I fully believe every
single iPad in the lineup will be
updated this year and out of all of them
I believe this one will have the least
amount of changes seeing as it already
has the landscape camera the new modern
design and support for the budget apple
pencil USBC now moving on to the iPad
Mini 6 this is honestly my favorite iPad
because of the convenience size fitting
perfectly into your hands for gaming and
watching watching videos being so small
and lightweight that is just so
comfortable to use the performance is
great the display is laminated with P3
colors it's got Touch ID at the top and
apple pencil to support with a USBC Port
that's plenty fast it's just a great
iPad for iPad things and I would
recommend it even if a new one is on its
way because honestly I can't think of
very many ways to make this better other
than giving it the landscape camera yes
yes the new one will likely come with an
a77 chip or maybe even M1 or M2 but it's
plenty faster ready for what I need so
it's a good pick now as for the iPad Air
that I'm using as a teleprompter the
situation is the same but I would
honestly avoid this one because it's
rumored to be getting an update soon
with the potential of a new larger size
and the M2 Chip which is quite a lot
faster and there might even be camera
changes on the back as well so to be
honest I would avoid getting the iPad
Air right now and finally we have the
iPad Pro Models which are the best and
most expensive iPads and for that reason
absolutely avoid them right now because
you are going to regret it we've been
getting tons of leaks and rumors that
show that the new 2024 iPad Pro Models
are coming in around 2 months with the
first major redesign since 2018
including brand new state-of-the-art
stacked OLED displays a new Apple pencil
3 the brand new M3 chip larger display
sizes and much more so if you've got
enough cash for an iPad Pro definitely
wait until March for the new models but
if you don't have that much money or
budget I'd recommend going for either
the iPad 10 right now for only 350 bucks
on Amazon or the iPad Mini 6 which is
also $100 off so it's just 400 bucks so
hopefully this video helped you make a
decision and if it did you'll find the
links to the best iPad deals in the
pinned comment below and be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
right above thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one